much is said about the special
relationship between the United States
and Europe the transatlantic partnership
to beat all others the legislators of
both sides are a crucial part of the
equation the European Parliament here
the two houses of Congress in Washington
reporter skims across the pond to
compare and contrast to politicians walk
us through some of the complexities with
the aid of an American historian Eric
Paulsen Republican from Minnesota a
congressman for seven years bantling uh
socialists and Democrats from Germany
who first became an MEP in 1994 and
historian Vincent Morelli from the
Congressional Research Service I
wouldn't say there were significant
power power differences between the two
they're all both are unique institutions
with their own we are strengths and
weaknesses but subtle differences
separate what each legislature can
actually do and initiate Congress rose
out of the ashes of the war of
independence in the 1770s today it's two
chambers the House of Representatives
454 members and the Senate 100 members
both are dominated by the Republican
Party making it problematic for Democrat
president barack obama to push through
his plans the european parliament is a
single chamber that rose from the ashes
of World War two it has seven main
political groups from the e use 28
member states it's dominated by the
center-right the center and the center
left the shakedown in powers is like
this Congress the federal budget foreign
policy tax collection senior
appointments and the removal of the
president by impeachment the european
parliament has co-decision and blocking
powers over the budget election of the
commission and some supervisory powers
it can't initiate legislation or raise
taxes on Foreign Relations it can only
advise every member of Congress on any
given day can introduce a piece of
legislation whereas in the parliament
you wait for the commission for the big
pieces of legislation an interesting
case study is teetav the transatlantic
trade and investment partnership being
negotiated by the European Commission
the US parliament is not directly
involved in the negotiations nonetheless
today finds the head of its
international trade committee bantling
uh Washington for talks now we are going
to the hello and you'll meet some
Congress men and give them auto to your
signal that we expect more ambitious
position from the US side and this
advice to EU negotiators take our points
on board otherwise it would be
problematic to get an agreement through
the Parliament the times where trade
agreements were negotiated behind closed
doors over onto capitol hill and the
meeting with Eric Paulsen a Republican
senator deeply involved in t tip and
very aware of the machinery and powers
sometimes the lack of them of the
European Parliament Parliament plays a
role reflect in public opinion making
sure the Commission is on track to
follow certain negotiating guidelines
and so we want to make sure we're having
a full conversation about what those
guidelines should be we do the same
thing in Congress as we advise our
president in those negotiations with our
trade ambassador and we think that'll
Bruce a better result is
mr. Paulson is also aware that key trade
agreements have been rejected by
Parliament before like actor the
anti-counterfeiting trade agreement
signed by several major economies but
rejected by the EU after em ep's felt it
eroded the rights of citizens they want
to make sure that they're responding to
what their constituencies of China are
important and I think the system is a
little similar the united states where
the parliamentarian car proletarians you
know ultimately they ultimately are
trying to give some guidance to the
Commissioner a new trade agreement with
Europe will level the playing field for
American companies they do things
differently in the States no doubt about
that but they see more similarities than
differences with the EU in the
implementation of democracy and that's
important it brings the houses closer
get them listening to each other
European negotiations are going to have
more support because these are our best
friends our best allies our values are
the same stronger bipartisan support so
I think there's going to be building
excitement actually about these
negotiations as time goes forward
knowing full well it's still going to
take you know up to a year or their
house to make sure that it's done
successful what next in the evolution of
the European Parliament's powers the
2009 Lisbon Treaty handed more of them
to it making the Commission and European
Council less obscure bodies managing
legislation affecting 500 million
citizens from behind closed doors but
any new powers would have to be made by
a new EU treaty and that's not on the
horizon yet their guns abide awesome see
how it's pratik tears not originally
struck a mine shaft it on da van wid da
beach later arbeiten mehsana basketba
non pas politique by shady and only for
vicodin about eels kasam dismissal burn
fat wagner to lahaina grocer competence
of items parliament as a game do you saw
her oddly Oscar food run in the case of
actor a really big wake-up call was
sounded to the European Commission
nevertheless attention in the division
of power remains much still resides in
the hands of member states individually
and collectively acting through the
European Council this is vitals normal
ish
in the commercial are often fear matrix
Laden d minor for hash and internets and
up comes and also on an owner battalion
dispela mentis does hudso fundamental
again not each lower assist not side
also target us hunt fatigue and off at
reg under the tile on the Democratic
version of us none are so handsome this
then is the principal message power is a
fluctuating thing never still it
diminishes and increases through
different epochs as much in the United
States as in Europe and right now here I
am eps it's changing gradually to their
advantage alright seems to be a bit busy